[Music]
what alright y'all I've seen my fair
share of internet videos I mean I have
like an entire segment dedicated to them
every day on my show matter how many
rabbit holes we fall into on the
internet we're all sure to miss some of
the best stuff but don't you worry I'm
here for you this is what I'm liking so
today I'm going to play a game called
guess the rest where I'm shown a video
I've never seen before and I have to
guess how it ends how will this go I
guess you'll have to guess the ending on
that one did you get it
stay tuned it gets better okay here we
go first ones up this guy Oh
oh no he is about to climb that pole or
try stripping out I hope it's the ladder
let's see what he's about to do oh my
god wait wait I don't understand what's
happening
wait no no no no do it again do it again
[Music]
is he like a member of Cirque du Soleil
like what is I would have never guessed
that was going to happen
that's incredible anyway okay let's see
the next one
do I like dogs oh we're thinking a lady
in there gonna oh they're gonna do the
lady in the [ __ ] thing where they do
the stupid goodies and kiss that's what
yeah that's what's gonna happen no hope
oh my god girl you almost got your hand
in your face eaten oh my gosh that's a
crazy dog okay go ahead cats
oh they're watching that fish there like
which ones going to get it okay I bet I
hope what happens is the fish like they
come at that fish that fish just
splashes and then they go running cuz
cats hate water
okay oh my god the fish was attacking
the cats do it again I did not see that
coming the point of this but I did not
see that coming look at how fast they go
can we eat what oh my gosh oh my gosh
that's so amazing
who does that though like whose setup
let's put this fish in a sink and see if
our cats will eat it like what this is a
weird thing okay
let's see what's this one that's a big
tire oh okay this guy is gonna attempt
to I think it's a guy can't see through
the shadows but I think he's going to
try and jump over the tire and I think
he's gonna epically fail what do it
again
oh my gosh the human body not mine but
others man hey that is incredible
what's that that's a tiger you ain't
getting that duck I think he's gonna try
and get that duck and I think the Ducks
gonna like flapping its face and scare
the tiger actually that's what I hope
happens if I wanna see it again
the duck goes under the water so the
tiger can't get it the tiger goes he's
like where the hell did it go that's
awesome okay a seal let's go thumbs I
feel like I'll walk like a seal okay
well going towards water so I mean I
know that they're gonna want me to sail
it's gonna get in the water and it's
gonna swim around but I don't think so I
think it's gonna be afraid of the water
it's gonna be afraid of the waves I hope
it is that's funny
oh do it again and oh it's a long day
and out but that's awesome seals are so
cute y'all alright y'all well I guess
I'm not so great at guessing the end of
Internet videos because dude let's talk
about the guy that jumped on the tire
and then like jumped off he's like a
ninja I want to be a ninja anyway I'm
not so good at guessing the end but I do
want to throw a big shout-out to the
reddit thread maybe maybe maybe for the
inspiration behind these incredible
videos I'll see y'all soon subscribe to
my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going